you really have to see this next clip i
already told you yesterday
and we just discussed in our previous
clip donald trump's
vaccine executive order that he signed
at yesterday's vaccine summit
which we don't understand donald trump's
executive order
says that the u.s government will work
to secure
coronavirus vaccine doses for the united
states
before other countries get them now
it's not really clear what the
enforcement
of that would be it's not clear what
enforcement is even legally possible
it's not clear what authority the united
states has to obtain vaccines for us
before other countries get them
we weren't the only ones confused by
this executive order
and yesterday donald trump's vaccine
chief
who i'm actually more or less happy with
he's been doing a relatively good job
at not politicizing the vaccine program
he's seemed immune for lack of a better
term
to pressure from pressure to say things
that he doesn't believe i'm talking
about dr monseff slowie
he was interviewed by abc's george
stephanopoulos yesterday and you have to
see this
george stephanopoulos says to him what
is trump's vaccine
executive order about like what does it
do and slowly doesn't even pretend he
just says
i have no idea whatsoever he just sort
of shrugs and raises his eyebrows
he has no this is trump's vaccine chief
no idea what trump's executive order is
about check it out it's like a greek
tragedy
can you explain this executive order the
president is going to be putting out i
don't quite understand he's saying that
foreign countries aren't going to be
able to get the vaccine until everybody
here in the united states
guess that it sounds like the problem is
the opposite right now pfizer has made
deals with other countries that are
going to limit the supply here
frankly i don't know and frankly i'm
staying out of this so i can't comment
i don't i don't know
but you're the chief science advisor for
operation warp speed
our work is is you know rolling we have
plans we feel that we can deliver the
vaccines as needed so
i don't know exactly what what this
order is about
just amazing optics slowly
just washing his hands of this all
together i have no idea
i'm not involved in it not even
pretending to try to explain it but the
key thing here
is actually what george stephanopoulos
says which is
the problem is the opposite trump's
signing an executive order saying
get us vaccines before other countries
thanks to trump
turning down a hundred million vaccine
doses in the late summer
other countries are going to get vaccine
doses before us the uk
already vaccinating people as one
example so
the the back story again if you missed
yesterday's show i'll quickly remind you
trump was offered back in late summer
the opportunity to get 100 million more
doses of the pfizer vaccine secured for
the united states and trump said no
and so pfizer went and sold those doses
to other countries
as they would obviously do and that
includes the uk uh
and some european union countries have
also secured vaccines
now we've learned that thanks to that
decision
the u.s is not likely to get a second
tranche
of the pfizer vaccine doses until june
of 2021. this is just because trump
turned down 100 million doses
so trump is now panicking and he put
together this completely flaccid
impotent executive order which appears
to do nothing
other than maybe make it look like he's
doing something to cover up that failure
from the summer when he could simply
have said yeah we'll take the doses of
course
and now you have vaccine chief dr monsef
slawy on national tv
saying i have no idea what that is that
is about
washing his hands completely and saying
i'm not involved now one interesting
thing
is that you can tell fear of trump is
palpably waning
as trump gets closer and closer to being
an ex-president
slowly himself might have answered this
question the same way at any point
but in total when you look at other
republicans and other people ancillary
to the trump administration
they seem more and more willing to just
say things as they are rather than
bending over backwards the way we saw
them do for so long to pretend that what
trump is saying and doing makes even an
iota of sense
now as far as the executive order it
again
feels sort of like when donald trump's
uh dad fred trump
was suffering from dementia and he'd go
to his office and he would
uh die call people on his phone but the
phone would only go to a secretary
and he would shuffle around stacks of
paper and sign things that were
completely meaningless
as if he was working nobody's really
paying attention anymore
and trump's executive order it does
nothing it's not even clear
what the enforcement would or could
possibly be we're getting into a very
strange kind of lame duck period with
donald trump and as a reminder
six weeks we have six weeks i believe to
the day
right i think january 20th is a
wednesday i believe we are six weeks
to the day uh of all of this
all of this ending and we will all be
much better for it
let's take a quick break make sure you
are following the show
on facebook facebook.com
davidpakmanshow we will talk about jenna
ellis now having the virus and i have a
bunch of other things to discuss with
you
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now and you can take advantage of
it by going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch from high-end
materials but one that
everyday people can afford and that's
why they have over
25 000 five-star reviews
because you won't find a better made
watch for
this great of a price anywhere else you
can get
big holiday discounts on all of their
products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video